jonathan turley joins us from our
Washington bureau he's a CBS News legal
analyst and a law professor at George
Washington University Jonathan good
morning good morning you wrote in a
piece for the hill that the Attorney
General's letter is about as informative
as a haiku highway sign so what actually
can we take from it actually I think the
most important takeaway is what is not
accompanying that letter which would be
indictments you know you cannot collude
alone and so if there is collusion here
one would expect that other people would
be charged the policy is you can't
charge a sitting president but that
doesn't apply to other people so the
absence of indictments would seem to me
to indicate that they did not find a
conspiracy of collusion because they
didn't indict anyone for that but so
much of of this report has left
collateral damage out there I mean you
have five indictments four plea deals
and the president now and his team are
essentially declaring victory can they
with all that out there well they have
really taken some hits below the
waterline there's no question about it
you know you've got dozens of people who
have been charged five people close to
the president all of that leaves a mark
and it's going to be hard to shake it
but let's not you know let's give to the
administration it's do if if the Special
Counsel found there was no collusion
that is a vindication for the president
it doesn't mean that he acted
appropriately it doesn't even mean that
the special counsel didn't find evidence
that could be criminal but he had
clearly indicated that he doesn't
believe that there's a criminal case to
be made so Jonathan based on what he has
filed in the past in the past indictment
indictments that there have been what is
the sense of Washington in terms of the
direction that this investigation went
toward waitron I think that the key to
remember here is that the Moller
investigation is narrower than the
congressional investigation many of
things that Congress is investigating
are things that were
into the Southern District of New York
so molar was much more focused because
of his mandate those congressional
investigations will continue but if
molar comes out and says look I didn't
find any evidence of collusion between
Donald Trump or the campaign the
Russians that removes the original
purpose of the mandate for appointing a
special counsel Jonathan so what happens
to this report if you're in the Justice
Department right now what's the
conversation it'll be an interesting
conversation because rod Rosenstein the
Deputy Attorney General wrote a
blistering memo against former FBI
director James Comey and like many
justice officials he objected to Co me
holding the press conference involving
Hillary Clinton where he said we're not
going to indict her
but here's all the horrible things she
did type of press conference he was
really excoriated for that and Rosen say
Stein has really maintained that that's
not the role of the Department of
Justice if you don't indict someone you
don't then trash talk or or give the
evidence that might have been used now
there is one difference here the
Department of Justice has this policy
that it won't indict a sitting president
so this creates a sort of artificiality
they're saying well he's not indicted
but that's only because you won't indict
him many people including myself believe
a sitting president can be indicted but
that's not the policy of the Department
of Justice so that really argues more
heavily in favor of the disclosure of
the report if this report is not
released Jonathan who actually gets to
read it in full well it is an executive
branch document and so presumably the
White House will eventually be able to
see this document I obviously people at
justice are reviewing it I would expect
that Congress would get some form of the
document but there is a lot of pressure
to release it in redacted form he cannot
legally release this unredacted as some
of the Democrats have suggested there
are federal laws that prevent that there
could be grand jury material
in this report that cannot be released
publicly so he has to scrub it but I
think that all of the the statutes
support in my view the release of this
report there is an exception under
Department of Justice regulations for
the release of this type of material
when there's a great public interest and
I don't think you could possibly
describe this as anything other than
great public interest Jonathan Turley
thanks very much for being with us this
morning we appreciate you